so you woke up this morning you checked
your crypto portfolio
what happened to my crypto lately
cryptocurrency prices have been going on
a wild ride
and a lot of it has to do with elon musk
look i know i sometimes say or post
strange things but that's just how my
brain works
the tesla and spacex ceo has a lot to
say about cryptocurrencies
often on twitter surprise you just got
eloned
while musk is not the only thing
impacting crypto prices
one thing is clear when he tweets about
cryptocurrencies it can move markets
and that power is unparalleled here's
how musk has amassed
such influence over cryptocurrencies and
why some experts are raising alarms
to understand just how influential musk
can be
take a look here on may 12th bitcoin was
continuing on a steady downward trend
running off of an all-time high the
month before at five o'clock p.m
the cryptocurrency was hovering around
55 000
and then at 606 pm this happened
musk tweeted that his electric vehicle
company tesla
would no longer accept bitcoin as
payment due to concern
over rapidly increasing use of fossil
fuels for bitcoin mining and
transactions
after the tweet went out the price of
bitcoin plunged more than five percent
losing around 150 billion dollars by the
end of the day
after that you did have a lot of people
who were really upset with elon musk
caitlyn ostroff who has been following
musk's influence on the crypto market
for the wall street journal
says that there's been speculation that
a lot of the selling after elon's tweet
was because retail traders weren't used
to the high volatility
people have to understand that this
thing this is a dice roll
they suddenly got nervous that they were
going to lose profits and sold
they were replying to him on twitter and
they were saying you know you just cost
me
x thousands of dollars because all of a
sudden
my investment portfolio was worth 5 000
and now it's worth maybe four but it
hasn't just been bitcoin
musk has tweeted about other
cryptocurrencies as well
take the once joke crypto dogecoin and
it keeps climbing
the meme inspired cryptocurrency nearing
nearly doubling over
the past week alone this ahead of elon
musk's appearance on
snl early on may 8th before musk was
slated to host an episode of saturday
night live
dogecoin was trading around 73 cents
investors had been pumping money into
the cryptocurrency
based on speculation that it could
finally reach a dollar
but that didn't happen during a skid he
performed in the guise of a financial
expert
the self-proclaimed doge father jokingly
explained what dogecoin is
it's a cryptocurrency you can trade for
conventional money
oh so it's a hustle yeah it's awesome
by the time the episode ended the price
of the crypto had plummeted around 30
percent
that comment alone rattled the
confidence that people had that dogecoin
could keep pushing higher
and people took profits and all of a
sudden it sold off but then
two weeks later musk tweeted a picture
of a shiba inu on a dollar
with the question how much is that doge
in the window
following his tweet the price spiked
dogecoin unlike bitcoin
doesn't really have an investment case
and that means that
dogecoin is really just a cryptocurrency
built on memes
the only reason it has any value at all
at the moment
is because elon musk first started
caring about it and then snoop dogg
started caring about it
and then all of these other like rappers
and celebrities started tweeting about
dogecoin
well these are two of the most recent
examples of musk influencing crypto
there are many more and there are other
forces at play
that have allowed musk to amass the
influence he has on crypto
over the last year there has been a
flood of new retail investors
largely driven by the rise in no fee
trading apps like robin hood
malcolm demirs an executive at the asset
management firm coin shares
says that no fee trading apps have
increased the popularity of crypto
because people can access more types of
assets on the same platform
it's also made really illiquid
cryptocurrencies of the past
much more liquid because there's now
much more retail participation
some experts say younger people
gravitate towards musk because they like
his idea of the future and see him as
rebellious
and demure says that musk's huge twitter
following is a big part of his influence
he has over 56 million followers
financial markets to some people
are a form of entertainment and so i
think what we are
seeing is the gamification of clout on
social media
where people are recognizing that they
can manipulate markets using social
media as a tool
but she says musk's influence on the
crypto market has downsides
there is a wide range of ways through
which market participants are are acting
on their desire to to buy and sell
cryptocurrencies
and as a result what we see is more
liquidity but also
more volatility when people like elon
musk are tweeting directly
to retail all assets are subject to ups
and downs
but as you can see from the big swings
on this chart crypto is especially
volatile
all of a sudden elon has reminded people
no this isn't just going up in a
straight line
it does come down and when it does it
can be fast
these market swings can have a very real
impact on retail investors
but for some the risk is worth it
because there's no fundamentals
it makes it really hard to try and
figure out where the floor is like where
the
fair value um and where the sell-off
should stop when it happens
and so you inherently wind up having a
much more volatile market
which is what appeals to some investors
for this like they don't want the steady
returns of
the s p where they have to wait you know
30 years to
get where they want to be they want to
get these fast
sharp returns some experts think that
musk's influence on bitcoin may be
waning
but for now his tweets continue to send
shock waves through the crypto market